[Música]
o quanto no dia a dia você tem
consciência do seu próprio corpo
aqui agora sentado nesse auditório o
quanto você está consciente das
sensações físicas da sua presença aqui o
contato com uma cadeira em peso do corpo
o quanto você tem de consciência de sua
cultura física neste momento o quanto
você tem de consciência do ar entrando e
saindo do suas narinas
neste exato momento o quanto você tem
consciência da vida dentro do seu corpo
neste momento enquanto está aqui olhando
pra cá o quanto você está consciente do
que você está vivo
sentado aqui olhando pra cá e finalmente
o quanto você tem consciência do que
você está com disse antes do que você
está a fifa
sentado aqui olhando pra cá bem vindos
não só bem vindos para este momento mais
bem vindos à sua própria vida e esses
questões esses perguntas que eu fiz pra
vocês agora me fascina
faz uns 28 anos na verdade eu dediquei a
minha vida a essas perguntas de certa
forma e me dediquei a uma pergunta
específica o que significa tiver em 2005
comecei a oferecer cursos de oito
semanas para pessoas com estresse e
sofrendo thedor aqui no brasil passando
em oito semanas um treino de maio mas
que é o valor que está
e nesses anos eu venho percebendo que
adultos nem inteligentes e altamente
capazes que nem vocês vivendo vidas
complexas e responsáveis ficam com uma
surpresa quando percebe o quanto anda na
vida e desconectados da sua própria
experiência do corpo
as emoções até dos atos e das decisões
não é curioso que estamos vivos e vivem
mais de tal forma que nossa própria vida
pode traçar partido
então o que significa viver viver é
vontade e tem um fato sobre essa vontade
que temos que é muito difícil refutar
tudo o mundo quer viver algo melhor
ninguém quer sofrer todo mundo quer
deixar para trás o estado mais sofrido e
viver uma vida melhor
todo mundo e provavelmente você está
aqui
seguindo essa busca provas ou mexe em
algum canto da sua vida existe algo que
você quer arrumar você quer viver algo
melhor vivendo com mais bem estar mas
passa né
mas peraí e um mau humor
será que o meu vizinho mal o mandado bem
estar é uma boa pergunta
não eu não sei sobre vocês mas quando eu
fico de mau humor
não é que eu quero brigar eu vou brigar
é talvez o irlandês mas nisso eu quero
me sentir um pouco mais produtivo sabe e
fina e se eu não conseguir brigar eu vou
fazer tudo mundo para o meu em faro
junto comigo para ter o mínimo de
companhia
todo mundo quer viver melhor
por trás de todos os atos humanos existe
essa mesma busca é e provavelmente vocês
conhecem alguém que quer emagrecer que
quer viver menos dependente do celular
quer não explodir tanto e rir mais quer
até ter mais contentamento das coisas
que já tem até esta busca esta vontade
está na bandeira brasileira
só que este busca não é só do povo
brasileiro
para onde você anda no planeta
você vai achar este mesmo movimento
o que une os seres humanos a pesado que
apesar das nossas diferenças
é essa busca é nós como vocês falam
então até se em si não conseguiu refutar
esta mesma verdade e se quiser pesquisar
aqui no tek você vai achar o americano
neurocientista é cedentes amarras que
fala exatamente isto
ok ok mas peraí emagrecer mas e
engordamos faço jejum ti e internet e
depois de duas semanas volta tudo ao
normal que prima e primo a minha
explosão para dar mais visado e de
repente público
então este viver não é tão fácil talvez
vontade não é suficiente e muitas muitas
vezes em salas de aula eu ouvi algo
assim como é que eu repito os mesmos
comportamentos que não quero e não
consigo viver a vida que eu quero viver
devo ter algo melhor dentro de medo que
só isto e presse que existem duas forças
tempo da gente uma força que quer
avançar em uma outra força que não quer
e nem sabe como e daí e se instala
facilmente x ou uma pressão pesada de
insatisfação que chamamos x stress
então a pergunta por que não conseguimos
viver a vida que a gente quer te ver né
porque tanto sofrimento desnecessário
não tem uma resposta única clara
claro né é mas eu acho que a resposta
não está na bandeira brasileira talvez a
gente vai achar as pistas e falas
cotidianas
é do da rua da mesa de jantar do
escritório nem os exemplos
a festa foi um for me senti um trecho
teve fora d'água
na hora que o bicho pegou
virei outra pessoa só depois me dei
conta daquilo que eu fiz
fiquei fora de e mail
fora todos frases cotidianas todos que
descrevem expressa todos os que escrevem
desconexão fora
é curioso o quanto você fica fora de si
no dia a dia em saná que quando não
estou bem eu faço justamente aquilo que
me afasta do meu bem estar
será que o custo de eu viver de forma
desconectada é que eu não consigo viver
daquilo que realmente eu quero viver
talvez não falta vontade mas talvez o
que falta é k acepção e presença
talvez os fatores subjacentes que impede
o nosso próprio bem estar são que o
agente não tá realmente vivendo
então eu quero terminar com 12 tipos de
desconexão e daí eu quero terminar como
algumas palavras sobre o valor da hora o
valor de estar aqui presente então a um
simples exercício é quando você caminha
para algum lugar você e fique consciente
x naqueles movimentos do seu corpo nas
sensações de cada passo que toma ou você
tende a usar a caminhada para a ruminar
sobre aquele aquela reunião chata com um
chefe ou o saldo preocupantes no banco
ou algo assim
e aí é que parece que é o ser humano nós
temos uma incrível tendência de viver no
piloto automático e no piloto automático
ficamos fora não ficamos dentro o que
acontece no piloto automático é que eu
realizo do uso três atividades que não
combinam ao mesmo tempo ou ficou
obcecado com resultado resultado
resultado home comemos e mexemos com o
celular
ou vivemos vidas tão carregadas que não
há mais espaço para renovação então no
piloto automático tudo vira borrão
ficamos desconectados e expressados aí
não vivemos de forma plena
no piloto automático
a experiência mas não prestamos atenção
nela e daí muita coisa importante passa
batido o piloto automático
então existe uma outra forma de conexão
que é parecida com o piloto automático
mas é mais nociva e esse forma foi
estrada há muito claramente no confronto
um caso doloroso escrito pelo irlandês
james joyce e nesse ponto ele descreve a
personagem principal sem o dof no início
do encontro assim senhor que o filho
devia à pequena distância do seu corpo
observando os próprios atos com olhares
furtivos e desconfiados diferente do
piloto automático ak temas atenção mas
não temos experiência
porque assim como o senhor dof vivemos
fora é distante daquilo que está
acontecendo é como se fosse alguém
olhando de fora pra dentro né e o senhor
de off parece que não participa na vida
parece que ele nem quer então sobre essa
desconexão é porque a gente cai nisso
uma das fontes é que vivemos talvez uma
infância e organizada pra agradar os
pais talvez para ser bonzinho o bonzinho
e mais tarde a gente não consegue se
livrar do olhar está no sempre olhando e
nesse estado que é a tensão alienada uma
simples pergunta que nem como estou
facilmente se torne como eu deveria
estar
vivemos longe e daí não sabemos mais o
que está acontecendo aqui no na atenção
a nada só temos uma impressão vaga de
como estamos e vivemos que nem senhor do
bonfim
outras fontes de alienação está
bombardeado constantemente por mensagens
de marketing a passar por uma crise tão
severa demais ou permissiva demais pode
ser aqui você não toma a
responsabilidade pela sua vida
outras fontes são reprimir a vergonha
saudável e viver um senso de culpa não
saudável quezado confundir euforia com a
verdadeira felicidade ou até receber de
um instrutor de mais luz amarela
orientação de observar os pensamentos
como se fossem não vende e aquela
vontade de querer matar como se fosse
algo distante no corpo de uma outra
pessoa
todos são excelentes fontes de alienação
se for pensar esses dois tipos de
desconexão do piloto automático e também
a linha nissan tem ou uma característica
em comum esse conexão com nossa própria
vida pode passar batido
mas peraí se eu for juntar em tempo real
a minha atenção com experiência né
aqui agora o que acontece nisso a gente
tenha prática de mães irmãs e acima de
tudo mais influente é internalizar o
valor de viver uma vida plena é sei quer
saber de novo e de novo que eu me perdi
no piloto automático e na atenção
alienada e é a opa peraí volte a se
abrir de novo e vou pra aquilo que já
está aqui é c e ter consciência do que
estou aqui vivo mãe fãs é no final a
habilidade de estar presentes com o que
já está aqui
seja qual for
então eu quero deixar com vocês uma
semente plantada
sejam bem vindos para sua vida aos seus
altos e os seus baixos
se é possível viver uma vida mais plena
e é possível cultivar a consciência do
que estou aqui agora olhando pra vocês e
vocês olhando pra mim e se for olhar pra
todo mundo aqui onde tem outros seres
humanos potencial enorme nestes
auditório
não somos o futuro e falando sobre o
futuro desejo a cada um de vocês
no final da sua vida que vocês têm
capacidade de olhar para trás e dizer eu
fiz o meu melhor
eu participei se a vida não é uma coisa
não é uma linha reta então a gente vai
se perder no piloto automático e isso é
que nem o senhor diouf para um belo
tempo então é faz parte do grande
despertar então está em suas mãos agora
o que significa viver bom bem vindos mas
mais do que isso volte sempre
e depois me conta obrigado